hello and welcome to my channel firstly  thank you so much for your time and  attention I really really appreciate it  so my name is Hisham azuz and I  currently work within a recruitment  industry so this channel is going to be  a mixture of me documenting my journey  in terms of building the podcast and  also my thoughts on what I learned on a  day to day basis I'll be documenting my  failures  I'll also be sharing my thoughts on how  I'm leveraging social media and those  types of tools to help me in my  day-to-day job and the sort of effect it  has etcetera so it's going to be a whole  host of things I'm really excited and  again thank you so much for coming to my  channel  [Music]